حريره خرسون لكنها لا تزال تحت النيران
القوه الروسيه قصفت هذه المحطه النفطيه
مساء الاحد الجبهه ليست بعيده جدا عن
المدينه المحرره والحرب لم تنتهي بعد لكن
هنا يحاول سكان استئناف في حياتهم شيئا
فشيئا يصطفون في طوابير طويله امام
المحلات التجاريه بعد اعاده افتتاحها لاول
مره منذ تحرير المدينه هذه العلامه
التجاريه عملت على تجديد بضائعها بالكامل
هنا
المفضله لدي منذ فبراير الماضي لم تكن تبع
المتاجر الى البضائع الروسيه وبالطبع لم
نشتري شيئا منها
حتى اكثر من ثلاث مرات حسب البضاعه
الى الوضع الطبيعي بعيده المنال اذ يجب
اعاده بناء كل شيء في المدينه السكك
الحديديه محطات القطارات وحتى المطار الذي
بداك مقبره عسكريه واسعه ينتشر فيها حطام
الدبابات والمركبات العسكريه فيما تحاول
فرق ازاله الالغام تفتيش المنازل والاراضي
تمت استعاده الخدمات الاداريه ومركز
الخدمات الاداريه يعمل الان 24 ساعه في
النهار نعم الله على استعاده الشبكه
الخلويه والنظام المالي
اكثر من اسبوع منشات حيويه ما حرم سكان
المدينه من التيار الكهربائي والمياه في
مرحله دقيقه مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء ازمه من
المتوقع ان تستمر لعده اشهر حسب السلطات